what do we think biden's going to do
about crypto i think it's more than
likely that
it uh he's going to try and clamp down
on it somewhere maybe but i wonder if
they're going to do fed coin
you know they've been they've been
talking about the federal reserve's
going to make their own crypto
and it was interesting i was talking to
uh i was talking to somebody about how
banking works anyway
because like your bank account there's
no real dollars there
the bank doesn't have the cash if
everybody
if everybody went to the bank right now
and asked for their cash they'd be like
that cash doesn't exist
it's it's in your account you can spend
it you can't physically hold it
so it's a really interesting way to
avoid a potential run on the banks for
instance right
back in the day people went to the banks
like give me my money because they were
worried the bank loaned too much out
there wouldn't be
any available but now the bank can be
like we can't give you your money but
here's a debit card that still works
you can still buy things with it because
your money is all digital
and i was talking to someone and they
said i was like how do they track
whether or not their money's actually
there
it's just it's it's like an archaic kind
of blockchain essentially
that institutions will track money went
from discount to this account
and here's the account numbers and it
goes to that account discount and
there's a ledger showing
all the transactions that were made and
that's it no actual exchange of currency
no hard exchange of any physical object
so then someone makes the blockchain and
it's like they kind of just
decentralized what the banks were
already doing
some centralized digital currencies have
a real value in venezuela
a lot of people uh bought and still buy
world of warcraft gold
because it was more stable and beautiful
than other vendors
still even to this day because you can
buy gold now on world of warcraft well
that's the thing they were they were
either farming the guild in world of
warcraft or they were like transferring
their currency to world of warcraft girl
because
uh world of warcraft girl was less
likely to inflate than venezuela and
bolivars
yeah but world of warcraft gold inflated
like crazy oh yeah
oh yeah i'm not saying it's stable but
it was more stable for a time than
venezuela's currency
yeah that's kind of a that's a very
serious indictment of venezuela
but i wonder when when we get hit by
that there was i was reading one article
where there's some big investor guy said
30 market hit at the end of the year of
this year
yeah 30 percent so i'm not gonna tell
anybody what they should or shouldn't do
but i'm going to buy a bunch of ethereum
me too yeah big ethereum update in july
yeah yeah you were saying they're not
going to have mining costs anymore
uh yeah so they're going to change the
way gas fees work
so uh i don't know all of the details
but it's going to stop going to miners
miners are not happy about this
and it's going to instead some some of
it will be burned with every transaction
so it's going to make ethereum more
deflationary
oh so instead of paying the miners
you're paying less of a fee but the fee
is
just being that's that's very
interesting
but the bottom line is it's uh they're
planning it to make uh gas fees less
wild than they are today
if you can build a way to naturally
deflate currency into the currency
that's how you avoid inflation obviously
it just guarantees it becomes more and
more valuable over time because there's
less of it
or it doesn't become less valuable
however you want to look at it that's
really weird
i mean i i do think that there's a
possibility that doge shows us the
system is collapsing as well
in that there are people who got rich
big time for no reason for a meme it's
it's a meme economy it's almost like
labor is is essentially meaning
think about this way imagine you're a
contractor i'm sure a lot of people
watching are contractors
you build uh pole barns or something or
some small structures
and you're like it's going to cost you
know ten thousand dollars for this you
know simple steel garage you wanted
and the guy goes uh hold on let me sell
some doge uh here you go man
and then you're like you should give me
10 grand to build this thing for you
and you're like you're selling doge what
does that mean oh yeah yesterday i
bought a bunch of doge and it jumped 30
30 you know 30 cents doubling its value
so now i'm just giving you i didn't do
any work for it but now you're you're
getting what you want
we are living in that world there was a
moment in january where like
uh in the same day i was you know
walking through my apartment building i
i overheard a conversation between two
people oh yeah my dog investment's doing
really well
i went to a restaurant the waitress was
talking about how her boyfriend made a
thousand dollars from joke everyone was
talking about it investing in it
that's why i i confidence is all that
matters
you know people thought for a while
people were saying litecoin was
the silver to bitcoin's gold and
litecoin is particularly valuable
bitcoin cash is up significantly
but it's all about confidence bitcoin
has confidence
big companies have invested in bitcoin
infrastructure dogecoin
has the second most level of confidence
in my opinion
the issue is that there's so much doge
it's a there's there's
a massive quantity of this it's probably
better to say ethereum has more
confidence
but i think doge is art might be even
more than bitcoin to be honest
for a few reasons regular a regular
person who looks at bitcoin and sees
sixty thousand dollars
says i can't buy it because they don't
realize that you can buy
fragments you can you know down to the
eighth decimal point but they see a doge
and they're like 60 cents oh i'll put 10
bucks in
yeah and doge is so volatile it goes up
and down so steeply that there's always
going to be like
a significant dip that you can buy in it
dude it goes up and down so fast because
of the meme
if you there are programs you can buy
that's buy and trade on algorithms and
you press start
and at the end of the day you made 10
grand wow because what it does is
it has a certain amount of money in a
certain amount of doge and it
buys low and sells high automatically
and looks for trends probably like when
a tumbles start to happen and it's
getting in and out
it's it's really simple it's like doge
hits you know yeah
so like if there's a certain percentage
spread it'll sell when it's high
and then when it dips back down it'll
buy again and then if it's a certain
period of time where it's only going up
it'll just buy in and then sell high
and it keeps doing this and it keeps
increasing the amount of currency and
those you have
so there that people have been doing
this for since the inception of
cryptocurrencies
i remember back in the day there was one
website i remember what it was called
but they had
hundreds of clones of bitcoin and people
would just make simple programs
that would buy and trade whenever one
would go up it would go down they'd buy
when it got they would sell and they
should do with all the different
currencies
people made a ton of money oh i gotta
find these doge algorithms
it's it's it's not even a it's it's it's
really simple it's like if increased
five percent
sell if decreased five percent buy it's
like
really ridiculously simple and so it
just sits there tracking the current
price
and it's going up and down and then it
buys it it sells and then it buys and it
sells and it buys and it slowly goes up
getting you more doshy and more cash
that's that's due to the volatility of
doge i mean day traders do this in
general
and you look for a particularly stock
you think is gonna spike and then as
soon as it does you sell it immediately
and then move on and you don't worry
about it
but uh i i i do wonder like that the
bitcoin
uh bull market's been going on so long
when it goes down it'll really go down
no
you think not nope i think a bitcoin uh
it'll have it has its periods um it it
hits 20k a few years ago and then
dropped down to like seven and everyone
was like no
and people some people mortgaged their
homes and they were panicking
and that was a huge mistake because if
they had just held onto the on
to the bitcoin it would be 60. there
were people who bought in at 20 000 and
when it tanked panicked and sold
thinking i've lost everything oh yeah of
course but my point is like
as the market expands as more people
become participants in it
the uh the panics grow more severe
because there are more people panicking
more people selling
when what's gonna happen is so recently
i think it dipped down to like 47 in the
past couple of weeks
and then a bunch of institutional
investors immediately were like yes
and they bought it all up for discounts
knowing that it's going to go up
i think a bitcoin will reach a bitcoin
will reach a million dollars
and probably more than that but i think
a million at some point and i think
particularly soon
for two reasons the buying power of the
dollar is dropping dramatically
and the investment into bitcoin
infrastructure is going up dramatically
so that means the value of a theorem in
bitcoin
they're literally gaining value as more
people want them the demand is high
but also corn is up 44
so if you're holding a dollar you can
only buy half as much corn
you're holding a bitcoin you can buy
even more corn
so bitcoin is going to go up it's
deflationary it is a funded amount
coins are lost every day demand is
increasing the price can only go up and
you know what
a one with eight decimal points
one bitcoin and then you put a period
and then you do eight zeros
you know what happened if you got rid of
that decimal point put commas
you'd get one million point zero zero i
think bitcoin had a million dollars
so that's just my opinion i'm not
telling anybody to do anything but i'll
tell you this
um you do what you think is right you
talk to your financial advisor
i'm going to buy crypto i'm also going
to buy i you know you know what i invest
in
things i can use because i'll tell you
one thing
an investment into a cryptocurrency or
gold or silver or anything like that
is an investment predicated upon your
belief
the system will not collapse the dollar
may lose value
inflation may happen but you do believe
you'll still be able to trade within the
system
if you're actually worried about the
apocalypse then you need to invest
in like a well water tanks
uh stores 30-year bins of beans
bunker yeah bunker because i'll tell you
if you imagine going you know the
apocalypse and you're like
please sir i need water i've got a
bitcoin he's gonna be like i don't care
how many bitcoin you got
like water is life someone's gonna walk
up and be like yo i've got
a sandwich and they're gonna be like
let's let's divide and trade the
sandwich because food is more important
yeah there are companies that uh sell
luxury bunkers to people
here in america oh yeah yeah there's
like there's old converted silos oh yeah
they're beautiful yeah i watched i think
i was watching a mr beast episode
you ever watched mr beast where i think
it was mr beast
he goes to one of these bunker silos
it's it's creepy stuff
but they're like they're like five foot
concrete reinforced
because they were meant for you know
missiles that wouldn't be blown up if
they were
you know missile striked or whatever and
there's like there was a beach room
where the walls are painted
then they have like bedrooms with tvs
for windows
so you can see out outside
yeah that's cool stuff yeah some people
went into like uh their bunkers their
luxury bunkers when covert started they
thought the apocalypse was here
wow yeah what other good things to get
if you're expecting that like
solar i would think like just some sort
of like renewable energy electricity
source and like a ham radio or something
some way to generate electricity yeah i
know that we don't rely on fossil fuels
like solar yesterday we were talking
about but
it's not really feasible it's like it's
like a society's functioning
electricity source not really a little
bit solar yeah but if all of a sudden we
couldn't pay our electric bill because
u.s dollars were
so deflated in value that no that can't
even get them anymore
that wouldn't happen right so the issue
is there's
the value of the currency will work to a
certain degree within the country it
won't work for
for uh imports so if your country is
dependent upon importing certain goods
then you're in serious trouble but trade
between two individuals within the
country
is probably going to be fine so the
issue
for a place like venezuela is that
they're dependent on on a bunch of
external corporations like
for flight for travel for transport and
it's increasingly coming true for a lot
of countries that you're dependent upon
other countries
goods and services so that being said
so long as you don't have a command
economy like venezuela your farms will
probably still produce
and they'll have to adjust prices for
the things you know that they that they
need to produce the stuff
it could make it so that you have to
work harder to get food for sure
but you'll still be able to get
electricity lumber
are we importing a bunch of lumber is
that why we went upstairs i do think we
import lumber
i do but uh i think we import a lot of
it actually i'm not entirely sure you
can use fly shortages
i think you can use i don't know if it's
an exact uh duplication of wood like
you're not getting exactly what you get
out of wood with him but a hemp fiber
you can
kind of constitute for wood i've heard
and it grows fast
hemp does well the housing market is
blowing up right now so i mean that
might be why they're
what do you mean like prices are
skyrocketing yeah yeah that's inflation
yeah and people are building yeah people
are building houses yep
well yeah and and here's the other
thing's going to happen because the cost
of lumber and steel is so high
the cost to build a house is going to go
up dramatically which is going to drive
the price of everyone else's houses way
up
now here's the crazy thing sounds like
an acid bubble to me yeah we'll check
this out
let's say you buy a house for two
hundred thousand dollars and you bought
it you know five years ago
now the us dollar is inflating like
crazy you still owe two hundred thousand
dollars
if the buying power of that dollar is
dramatically reduced
that means you owe less labor on your
loan
and then your house is going to
skyrocket in value because of inflation
so when you hear these people say don't
worry inflation's a good thing
i guess you know for americans because
we basically control the petrodollar
might actually be now your savings will
be completely decimated right
so that's bad your asset value through
the roof
yep the hard hard assets will retain
their value
and what will happen is i'll put it this
way ian if i owe you a dollar
right now a dollar can buy a candy bar
i say that basically i owe the amount of
labor to produce one candy bar to ian
i'm going to wait a year now a dollar
can't buy a candy bar anymore
it can only buy a quarter of a candy bar
i owe you less physical goods so are
they gonna are they gonna enforce like
yeah we know you said you were gonna owe
a hundred grand but that underground's
worth 400 grand so you owe us 400. nope
they can't do that you can't do that i
mean i guess if somebody has like a
fixed variable loan they can like drive
the variable rate up for some reason or
whatever but i don't know how that works
so
but uh yeah if you owe
a hundred thousand dollars on your house
and then the currency in flights and
then when you think within a year
it hyperinflates imagine people are
shoveling money into the street because
it's worthless
you go to your bank and you're like uh
here's the money i owe you and you just
shovel it off from the ground and throw
it at them
so the system can't work that way people
will take out loans to buy
assets and then when the asset triples
in price they'll they'll sell off
half of it pay back the loan with a
profit take out it's
rinse repeat ponzi scheme what they what
what uh
i can't remember which outlet was an
investor outlet said the good news for
inflation is it means that your wages
are going to start skyrocketing as well
and i'm like it's funny you think that's
good news it's good news for people with
no savings
you got nothing to worry about you got
no savings nothing's going to collapse
on you
so it is technically technically a good
thing
now for a lot of people who are like
middle class who have a decent savings
no real hard assets it's pretty bad for
you
so you don't want to be holding well i'm
not going to give anyone advice on what
you should do but i'll say i would not
want to be holding us dollars
which is kind of a problem because you
know you use it for everyday
interactions
but for poor people they're probably not
going to notice
they're going to be like the prices are
going up they're going to their job i
need a raise the business is going to
have to do it
then you know they work at walmart then
walmart's going to have to increase the
cost of goods across the board to pay
higher salaries
or to pay higher hourly wages and then
the people who have a loan
on their car are going to be like wow
when i took this loan out
for ten thousand dollars i was making 10
bucks an hour six months later i'm
making 20 bucks an hour
my loan was basically cut in half in
terms of the amount of work i have to do
to pay it off
so win for certain people i guess and
then everyone else around the world will
be forced to contend with our
hyperinflation because we're america
we'll blow them up so
banks that would put a lot of burden on
the banks that send out the loan so
would you expect that banks will stop
giving out loans
say that one more time if the if if the
burden then would fall on the banks that
loaned you 50
000 that's not only worth 25 when you
pay it back that's their problem does
that mean that they're gonna stop
handing out loans because of that
potential risk is that normally what
happens before uh
if there's hyperinflation yeah maybe
maybe another question this gets into is
how long will america be able to just go
around the world blowing up small
countries without any serious opposition
china is rising very very quickly
not long i don't think not long yeah i
actually tend to be
a 15 maybe someone you mean seven
maybe 2020 is when they're expecting
china to overtake the us's economy
we know about thucydides trap so
i don't know what were you going to say
alan uh i i think china is so
it can be a little bit overrated if you
look at history
rising powers often don't beat the
declining power because the declining
power tends to have
more allies and more diplomatic clout
that it's built up over many years of
being the dominant power
this is exactly what happened with uh
britain and germany germany was
on course to overtake britain its
industrial capacity before world war one
but britain won because it had more
allies
had an empire been around for longer had
all that dip all of those diplomatic
resources that it turned into these
alliances and it was able to beat
germany through coalition coalition uh
you look at china
china is sort of on its own because
america will have japan taiwan
uh maybe south korea south korea might
not want to get involved because you
know it's much more vulnerable than say
japan
by the ocean but america will have a lot
more if it came to like a confrontation
with china america would have a lot more
allies and what allies were trying to
really have
russia it comes down to russia again the
great wild card like if hitler hadn't
invaded russia he would have won the war
it seemingly at least that the math kind
of shows that well if he didn't hesitate
there was that famous battle whatever
where he that his what i can't remember
what happened no no no moscow moscow
they were right they were like a hundred
people
inside moscow and the right had divert
to stalingrad something like that they
they hesitated
allowing russia to uh to generate
reinforcements essentially yes they
could have taken moscow but they decided
to
go elsewhere man well hubris i guess
he thought he could do what napoleon
couldn't but if russia gets involved
then you could potentially start a whole
domino effect where europe gets involved
as well and then you have like a genuine
world war in your hands
right yeah so invest in uh a bunker i
guess
yeah they're in love with your friends
and family we had a guy on from a
a place called fortitude ranch and
they called in their members the
like in october just before the election
saying like the potential for volatility
is higher than normal
i don't think they really expected the
world to end but they put out a call
like a decent uh you know a decently
high single-digit percentage of
something bad happening
you know genuine fear that
yeah something look this instability is
not going to go away you know why
i mean you make a good point about the
media being the problem brian stelter
is is a dangerous guy um i think you
know cuomo's probably worse
but he is because he's trying to make
sure that everyone stays agitated
anxious and and suffering from anxiety
attacks all the time
like january 6 is over dude it's not
happening anymore
it happened it's gone away but he wants
to make sure these people only stare at
this
and these hearings and people are just
shaking terrified of the far right
meanwhile there actually is a problem of
far leftists going around rioting
protesting burning down buildings
and they ignore that so he's keeping
people distracted from the real problems
while keeping them
in a consistent panic attack state over
something that happened four months ago
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel
youtube.com tim cast irl monday through
friday at 8pm where you can leave
comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time